one summer I went to Sierra Leone it
actually do research and there you get
to a certain point I think in the
research process we just have too much
information and it's really hard to
figure out where is the right way to go
and I actually put the project into a
drawer for a bit and focused on si
nombre which was a story about
immigration and stayed more local and so
I put it away for about two years and
then when I read that book it sort of
brought it all back and there was
something about stripping away all the
context I'm focusing on the experience
this boy that seemed far more not only
emotionally powerful and stirring but
also effective in terms of just getting
to the heart of what it's all really
about and not any of the reasons for the
wars
was it important that the book like the
movie is kind of a political that you
don't know exactly where you are or why
the war is being fought was that part of
the appeal yeah there was that there was
the fact that there was necessarily a
white Savior in terms of a structure
away into the story there was no exotic
ism there it really was here is a human
being experiencing this thing well I
think initially when I read the script
you know it was there was no description
per se on what the soldiers would look
like or specifics about that and you
know typically you do your research and
a lot of what you're finding that comes
up is rebel soldiers you know the
children or boys and regular clothing
and when I got a chance to talk to
Carrie you know about this show he just
mentioned to me you know and the
research that he had done he mentioned
this you know this this faction but this
army called the Commodores and I
immediately looked it up and you know
thinking I had never seen it and it was
they're fascinating and they're
beautiful and it was it was it's you
know where the Commodore where are they
from Sierra Leone okay so what we did in
the I did another draft the screenplay
last year before we started production
and that one was a pretty major rewrite
actually of the trap that been around
for like the last eight years and I had
news since we were finally going to
production I could be a little more
specific about certain things which I'd
left sort of blank or as placeholders
before so I decided to sort of base a
lot of like the political parties the
factions and even the armies loosely
based on Sierra Leone and Liberia and
change names so the NDF need of defense
forces is based on the civil defense
forces although also known as the
commodores which is basically a Mende
Mende fighting tribe in Sierra Leone
that then once the war went into Liberia
to oust Taylor
they became Lord Lu Rd and then the
government soldiers are based on the
junta that also took over in Sierra
Leone the rebels are based on like the R
u F rebels
we call them the P LF so they're all
kind of have illusions to real things
right and because they're not real
Army's men what did you see is it mostly
found objects how do they go about
putting together their their outfits
well I think for in terms for the
Commodores you know as you see in the
scene where they were getting initiated
almost by the high priests and and
they're given garments you know their
their their little necklace and their
shirt and then as they go along you know
they're protective those little amulets
you wonder what those little square
things they're you know they're
religious and base and their protection
from bullets you know they're you know I
think you see them getting fired at and
sort of showing them that they you know
are they can't be hurt they can't don't
worry you know you're going into battle
with protection and then as they go
along you know whether they there's
rules that they have to follow you know
and if they break rules or they do
things wrong you can you know you could
purchase more pieces hats or headbands
you know or purchase more protection if
you're feeling unsafe or you're feeling
like you've made your mistakes if you
would show this movie to a hundred
composers probably 95 of them would say
we're gonna have this Western drum we're
gonna have this Western of Western
African drum Western African guitar sure
you clearly didn't do that yeah I mean
the first thing we tried was was much
more Western sounding in general like
like you know European or American
sounding with a lot of our Kestrel stuff
a lot of pianos a lot of brass a lot of
more traditional percussion and it just
felt too regional it fell to a colonial
it didn't feel like the right thing it
felt too regional or you know
specifically a European sounding and we
thought it would be a lot cooler to kind
of have a score that that no instruments
sounded like it had a place where it
came from
almost every instrument in that score is
some instruments processed in a way
where you can't tell what it is for
example a lot of the bass sounds of
violas pitch shifted down four octaves
which there's no way you'd know that but
although it's like
they're actually distorted pitch shifted
violas a lot of you know our bell sound
ended up being a carry at one point was
like it would be really cool if this
kind of had a submarine sonar type sound
of some kind and so I did some digging
and found a submarine sonar sound and
that's the bells you just took down a
couple octave over no right an octave
Wow but all the boom-boom bells are all
submarine sonar was interest the first
person who cast and how did you find
Abraham what was the process of
discovering him yes a dress was the
first cast him about a year before he
started production and once he came on
board we sorta had an idea of when we'd
be shooting because these guys were so
busy and so then it was sort of like a
backing into that date I had to do my
rewrite of all the changes I promised
him for his character just to get him on
board know I really wanted to make the
changes anyway but I just knew I had a
shorter period of time and do it in and
and then we knew we had really start
casting but will first be a to hone in
on a country then we had to start
casting and I knew no one to shoot in
West Africa it was always sort of an
uphill battle in terms of convincing not
only the producers but the finance ears
and the bond company and Sierra Leone
and Liberia were basically out Nigeria
had just recently they've done a big
production there that they had problems
on so that was kind of in if India fee
sort of prospect so Ghana was really our
last opportunity to shoot in an
english-speaking
West African country and because of
interest his contacts that we were able
to make some important connections
within the government not only with the
military but also with Minister of
Finance in terms of getting all this
equipment in another country without it
being taxed and to figure out if you you
know if Ghana was really a viable
prospect and it was so once we're in
Ghana it was about we knew we're gonna
have to cast everyone out of that
country we just didn't have the budget
to fly people in from other countries so
the search for all the kids began
obviously with the priority being on a
GU and Harrison Nesbitt our casting
director amongst a team of probably six
local Scouts would go out in the
communities schools
church groups any sort of like like
Civic Centre you can imagine where kids
would gather and Abraham
plays augu was found on a Friday
afternoon playing soccer after school
with some older kids and Harrison was
this just this white guy watching him
play soccer and yeah asked him come over
and they thought they're being scouted
for a soccer team and then they found
out it was just for a movie but Abraham
was into it you'd like the idea and so
one of the things about when you're
casting on actors is just kind of to be
able to gauge they're not discipline but
like their commitment to the project
because we need them to show up every
day once we start filming them we got to
hope they're there and so I run a pretty
lengthy tryout sort of thing if you will
and we sort of wilted it down like 30
kids we thought were sort of interesting
and Harrison was basically looking for
any kid that had charisma like one of
the kids and we had a 300 kid wide
casting set call and one of the kids
like stood up on a table and said we
demand sandwiches and water and that was
a kid named Randy who would be one of
the other machine-gun bears and one of
the kids in the camp that goes back to
war so Randy like you know there's one
of those guys it's like you're like okay
you you're coming with us
troublemakers the lesson this I'm gonna
get a get ahead in Hollywood make a
scene is that the yeah just a stand out
keep going
so Abraham was just one of those guys he
was more of an observer where the kids
the kids had clearly much more
personality on screen but I also know
just because you allowed us doesn't mean
the most interesting and I actually
noticed that Abraham was way more
concerned with like kind of explaining
to all the other kids what was going on
and being responsible rather than sort
of just being himself and being free so
I'd asked Harrison and Zoe are acting
coach to sort of separate him the next
day I came in so he could just we could
just focus on the scene what he could do
and that's where I started to see like
this he was probably our best if not
only hope an ague but there was no
moment before shooting where I was like
got it all right we got the kid was very
moment in shooting when you realize the
day we shot that scene that one er the
ends with him killing that woman because
the whole scene rests on him I can't you
can't fake it with cutting yeah or
cutting away at the right moment
he's got to live it all the way through
and especially the moment when he looks
up you know the hole in the ceiling and
sort of speaking to God it's a pretty
unbroken performance from a non actor
can you imagine how the film might have
turned out if you were shooting any
other place and how did Ghana become a
character in the film I'm glad they're
here at least you're here for this
because it's like I always get this
question about hard it wasn't that well
whether to do for it it's always good
here on the peoples perspective because
I talked about like and a lot has been
made about how difficult it was and
who's and I spoke a couple weeks ago and
we're like we don't want that to be the
story of the production because it
really is about the collaboration and
how especially for the Westerners who
went over there to work it was probably
like one of the most unique working
experiences that I ever have and that is
because of of our not only because of
our colleagues in Ghana we were working
with but I think the ambition of the
project in the period of time we had to
do it in and so that urgency
you know leaked into every single shot
we had there I mean those 15 minutes
because were basically Equator so
there's no magic our take on magic five
and a half minutes but like the hour
leading up to that five and a half
minutes would be the most productive
hour you would see anywhere like
everyone was hustling to get these shots
because they I think the whole crew
became invested in it every Sunday we
would show scenes that we shot the
previous week like we'd have like beer
and pizza and that stuff and the kids
would get to see all their work as well
and get it start to understand oh this
is what we're doing and this is the
fruits of it and I think that really was
huge for morale cuz by the end of it it
was every Sunday I think all the extras
were coming everyone wanted to come and
see what they'd done that week well you
were also giving out awards to the
awards well you know every week you
would get this together by the way it
was the hardest thing I've ever done and
not in the way that you think physically
yes emotionally yes but because you're
stepping outside I had no idea I asked
him in the movies too hearted we were
going I said where we gonna live are we
gonna live in a hut or you know what am
i you don't you don't have no idea what
you're expecting she would've been down
for the hut I was in I was in but you
know we didn't have racks that were made
we didn't have the the things that the
custom were accustomed to in the States
so yes she did all of her aging in a
cement mixer yeah
innocent make circles you didn't have a
big enough washer no no no there was
yeah one water tiny and everything Oh
dryer but the water the cement mixer
save time you didn't have time you know
I had a crew I'm divergent but I had a
crew that mostly locals I had a couple
people that came down from the states
that were wonderful but the local crew
they were amazing they never stepped on
a film set before they had no idea what
we were doing they looked at me like I
was crazy every day but they worked so
hard and the creativity that they
brought from being from the country that
they put into it you know where to find
things and going into the bush to wrap
those boys everyday that brought you
know I think a little bit to the film
that that I you know the little part
that I couldn't bring because of them
but the awards every week where you know
you know best I don't know most well at
the end was like Most Valuable Player
you know everybody one week it would be
given to one person and they would have
to decorate the cup and then the next
week and somebody else would add it so
but it gave everybody a sense of
camaraderie and I and I will say it
though lastly though this is the most
collaborative I've ever worked with a
crew you know I mean we were all in it
together and if if a camera equipment it
needed to get to the top of the hills
somebody else was doing it didn't matter
what department you were in everybody
was in it for everybody and so
supportive and that's what this is what
I'm so passionate about this film
because not necessarily is it so proud
to being able to work on something so
beautiful but the experience that I have
is to change my life I mean forever you
know in a wonderful way